THERE REMAS E TOS WAR IN EEDOM
BUT WEN
EXCLUSIVE. GIES TO SUBVERT  CAE
THEN-PRESIDENT'S SON TO
E THENHOUSE F OTE, WHAVE MULTIP
PATHS.
C THEM ALL. PATHSLL  TRIED F FI
LEADING UP TEVENT 6t S NOVEMBER
5t
THAT WAS WHE LOOKE
TH DONALUMD
LEGITIMA.
AMONG THE STRATEGIESITE DATE, TL
EXERTED PRESSURE O
UMP JR QUOTE
ICANS RO WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN, N.
WE GET TRUMP ELSO FOR
OBE N R HAVEOT CONOL
R IT
ANS RESS JANUARY1. REC
OBION CO FROM
A AND/OR
CAPITOL
QUONAL LT MESS
UNQUOTE. TOTAL LEV
THERE S LA
EXHE WHITES SOME OF THEM WIT
HOUSMMUNICATR
WHEN THATEENT.SA THAS CH FOR
YOU WAT THE
HOUSE, DID YOU K PNSTHELL,E,ANHG
IT'S INVALUABLE.
LOOKED LIKE DONALD TRUMP WASOTTE
GOING TO W THE EN WA TIME IN THT
ERE WAS A LEVEL OF DESPERATION
AMONE
PRESIDENT TO HANG OTO  WAYOSSIL
YOU D UMORS OF IDEAS.
I SHAROR SUPPOSED
A TELEVISION INTERVIEW THEAFTET.
THE RESUS EN
TOLD TO STANWNUSE, Q.
THINGS WER
KIND OF STRATEGIES
OF WHAT TO DO.
AND I THIN TEXTRRDALING.
T IN FED
GOVERNMENTS
SPECIFIC REFERENCES TOILINLAWSU
THOSE E  FILED.
AND THEY LOST MON 60 .
FRAUD.IDENCE OREAD VOTER
G CHANGED IN
WON THOSE STATES.HO NEED
FOLAWSUIND
DONALD TRUADY ENRE S BEINGEVAUD
LOE ST>>S KIND OE ING THING ABO
LIE ITSELF.E HOSE
SENIORITE HOUSE HAD ACCE TO
INTERNAL POLLING THAT PROJECTE
LOSI
ALWAYS COMETY BUT THRE THEN
AT THAT TI, RENOT FAR OFF FROM H
BEROE IOOF T T
BEFORE IT WAS  THE
DEMOCRATROY
OR WAS EVECOMPLETE, THEY WNG OFM
ABOUIS
UST HOEP
JANUARY 6th COMMITIS GRE GETTIN
RMATIOST
ESIDENT,
INING NCLUDING HISER CHIEF OF S.
THAT'S
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THIS
US.
IS AROUND THE CORNER.
TRUMP RUNNING
OFFICES, STATE K SECRETARIE S
AS INSTAOYN
E ATIVES AND T
SENATE FOR P LIC
SOMETHG AGAIN,F HE
TTOEVERS IN PLACE TO TIONAL CO
AYH OF THIS YEAR, A
E CALLED THIS ALL A,OUP IN SEARL
RYVET  THECALLED EASTMAN
THERE WAS NO CONSTITUTIOWA, WHAT
OTHER
THAN I THINK IT'S EXACY
I MEAN IS LL
TALKING.
TH HOW
TOTIC
LY T
OVERTHROW THE RIGHTFUL  OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
CANNOT BE DISMISSED AS,KNOW, DA
IN WRO